all right good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen
um welcome to this climate change panel
meeting
um
the last one I'm
scheduled to take the part in so we'll
see how that works out when the future
brings itself around
um so we'll go straight to the agenda
and
sunglasses on so I can see
um item one apologies
yes good afternoon sir
we have apologies from councilor
Pemberton
okay
item two disclosures of Interest
nobody up there
up there yeah
cancer put together
is she here yes I just want yeah thank
you chair I just want to declare in
relation to item five uh the art of
England Forest is a charity in my ward
um and I've been pre-planting with them
okay thank you very much anyone else
you've usually depart you've declared
your's blanket anyway haven't you
okay
thank you
item three minutes
to confirm inside the last minutes I've
got I've got no issues with him and it's
from that time yeah
yeah anybody else have any problem in
the minutes at all no
okay can we just agree with that then
please yeah
item four public participation
to receive questions from the public
to members of the climate change panel
notice I haven't been given in
accordance with the climate change panel
public partition procedure rules
thank you so we'll move on to these
questions
um are we just going to read are we
going to read these are we going to get
the um
Stephen do you want to give your
question personally or are you happy
with the written the written question
yes sorry
can I just mention one other thing
um which might be hopefully be relevant
it's about
um
the you know actions and whether or not
we're reviewing
um the 20 in 2020 end of 2023 timer to
climate UK will be issuing scorecards on
every individual District Council in
fact every Council across the country
and their performance and that might be
very relevant when we are considering
doing action plans because we have to do
the action plans but we you know we our
performance will be on public display
across the whole country compared to
every other Council therefore we we must
do the action planning to make sure that
we can get achieve a high score
okay thank you so once you've set the
plan you have to make it work then yeah
uh it it no it it has to be reviewed and
they they will look at the review of
these uh of the action plan the utmost
up-to-date version of the action plan
and then do a scorecard result on that
Council and compared to every other
Council across the country at the end of
this year okay well the state we're in
the with the elections coming up that
would be a job for the for the new
Council to do that review so we'll uh
we'll see how that sort of pans out over
the next two or three weeks
do you want to present your question you
know
just on the left-hand side
okay
thank you um okay so the question is
about an update to the the
um last climate action plan published by
the council which was published in
October 2021
um so it seems like we're cut a long
story short um cut the question short it
seems like we might be due an update on
this um and the question is basically is
the council willing to uh to publish a
point-by-point update on the the points
contained in the plan
uh and is the council willing to commit
to a kind of regular period for review
of this plan uh
so um
you know to answer the question to to
keep on coming back to this plan to keep
referring back to this plan is surely
quite important for keeping on track and
also for keeping the public engaged and
involved and seen as the actions
already in in place in the plan you know
I don't seem to be adequate to to the
the council's targets I think everyone
will probably admit that because the
targets are very ambitious
um you know to to come back to it and
look for new ideas would surely be
valuable
um there's the second question the
second part of the question was about uh
public engagement
um
about an update to the council's
communication strategy which was
published and accepted by cabinet at the
same time
um I'm just trying to
call the question to make it as quick as
possible but um
yeah so it just it would be about
um
whether we could be whether groups like
us could be more involved in in
contributing to these plans because you
know it's it's easy to come along and
ask one question and then get one answer
but you know that that's that does allow
us to participate in in the process but
it also you know keeps us as armed
length and and it's established
establishes a barrier whereas whereby
you know we we can't you know ask two
questions we can't contribute more we
can't have more regular conversations
and I think that's probably the energy
in the community and the energy in our
group to to to be involved more than
that so you know it is the council
willing to
um commit to a regular
um stakeholder engagement
um
event on its climate action plan
um I would say that the way that things
constantly and rapidly move in with the
with climate change we would need to
review on a regular basis anyway however
I can't personally commit to that now
because obviously this is the last
meeting we'll have of this
Administration
things may be very different
for the next meeting in two months time
um so my recommendation to whoever is in
this position that they should review
them and and to get some public feedback
and whatever else and uh I I think it's
better for us to work together than to
work again against one another and I
would be recommending from this meeting
that regular reviews take place and a
bit of consultation goes on in the
meantime as well thank you so would you
be willing to recommend a particular
periodicity to that so annual and so on
I can't say how long it will take or
when it would be done by
um but like I say I'll be passing that
on that it that it needs to be done and
can can be done into the future and
hopefully by the next meeting a couple
of months time things may well have
settled down again and I can give you
better feedback on that question okay
and Could you
um address the the idea of a public
engagement a regular kind of stakeholder
engagement as well I I think that would
be a good idea I have to say
um so that we fully understand what
local people want
um because for me one of the big
problems I have is that
um when people come with sort of very
highfalutin ideas I like to see things
that are going to help the people that
live in the district so you know I mean
as long as the public participation the
people that work at it come back with
ideas that work for our district rather
than for National stuff then I'm more
than happy to do that
comes to that's how Dave Bob wants to
come in then counts the Crump then
cancel the play together okay uh Dave
Barber first then David
yeah it was just um information for for
counselors and and for Mr noria as well
um there was a full point by Point
review of the climate change Action
Program presented to the overview and
screwinger committee on the 3rd of March
um and I'm very happy to send you a link
to that it's uh so so it's really
addressing the first part of your
question
um which does sort of provide that point
by Point uh update including updates and
some of the associated documents like
the communications plan and the uh
funding strategy and so on so I'm very
happy to send you a link to that Mr
Murray
who's the next one
uh cancer Crump next please
thank you chairman yeah it's just a
couple of things I know that um it's
part of the budget process
um I I was on the review Tusk and finish
group was chair of everything scrutiny
and there is the climate change
initiatives
um which I think there was a question
asked at uh four Council now if you
remember rightly it's gonna be about 1.3
million the balance at uh the end of
that then this financial year so there
will be significant amount of money
available for initiatives that
um Can Make a Difference obviously that
we need to spend the money wisely uh and
efficiently and make um make the best
use that that financing so I think that
there is the opportunity to do these
things I'll take on Mr Norris point
about consultation
um yeah we want to know you know I've
never been a believer of imposing
initiatives on people but listening and
responding to people as well and thirdly
I think our Mr narica remember me at the
planning committee meetings where I've
I've supported soda farms in particular
um and I think I'll corrected some of
his his speech back as well so
um I think we've got to look at this
properly let's spend the money wisely
let's consult properly
um but not spend too long talking about
spending the money or too long about
Consulting
um it'll be for the new Administration
in in my uh to get on with the job as
they say okay
thank you councilor Council Puerto Gala
yes so the issue of stakeholders
engagement and also engagement with our
residents have come through and through
uh through public questions
um and actually we uh I think one of the
um the recommendations of the task and
finish group was to have a climate Forum
uh which was you know as part of the
Safety Council to convince this forum as
part of stakeholders engagement and I'm
disappointed that that is as not
happened uh for the past three years uh
what while it was raised and raised and
raised so I hope that going forward uh
we can organize such stakeholders
engagement and actually bring all
Community groups Parish councils um
together and that role is to you know
convene that so just to
um yeah comment on on the fact that
um you know this this Council have um
I've not done that yet
okay thank you came to the junior
um just going back to what I said about
the climate UK and the scorecards they
are actually awarding 10 of their score
will be for collaboration and engagement
as part of that collaboration and
engagement not only will they be looking
at the climate action plan but they'll
be looking at climate public engagement
strategies and how they are carried out
the joint needs assessment strategic
needs assessment uh the Health
Partnership pages of the public Pages
for the district council's website and
the local Enterprise partnership Pages
just to show that we've actually had
engagement and collaboration with all a
major
variety sections of Engagement so it
will be public in general but it will
also be particular groups like Health
particular groups like business
particular groups like
um the
um the needs the way that the
Partnerships work together to County
Council et cetera Etc so 10 of that
scorecard will be collaboration and
engagement
thank you
let's just say it's worth knowing that
because as we go forward if we will be
judged by that
councilor crumpy coming back in
maybe a leftover the uh Mr chairman
sorry I'll turn it off because the dog
was the dog was around
um yeah it's just the um
the collaboration point so I'm watching
on from cancer Junior's point is that uh
there's quite a bit of money at the
County Council the green shoots funding
uh and I know that some of my County
Council parishes have tapped into that
um I was gonna say tucked into the
National Grid but that's not quite the
one tucked into the the side of the
panels uh to to get solar panel funding
um and if if you can get people working
together and get money from different
parts I can certainly get a a bigger and
better outcome so I think that's that's
really positive so
thank you very much
um yes thank you and thank you to Dave
for sending me through immediately the
the update that he he mentioned
um I mean I appreciate your point that
we're just on the cusp of Elections and
you know it will potentially you know
things will potentially change but I
guess the parties will remain the same
and uh you know people here will remain
influential in those parties so I hope
that uh you are able to to I mean I was
talking to Darren Pemberton recently and
he was saying he recognizes the format
is perhaps not ideal and we could
perhaps look at changing that so
um I hope that you will all take away
that there is perhaps a need after the
elections to revisit processes and to
talk about these things and we're very
happy to be involved with that and
um probably it would be nice if the
update that David sent me was updated to
the website because uh I couldn't find
it there on the climate change section
okay I'll speak to about getting that
done
um like I say we don't know who the
administration will be the panel it will
depend who who owns the ball after after
the fourth of May
um as to how that game goes so uh yeah I
look forward to seeing it's interesting
to see how it'll transform and move
forward but in the meantime I'll speak
to people on my side of the gulf if you
like and um and see where we can move
things forward hopefully that fits in
with what everybody else wants to thank
you okay thank you
next question is from Richard Thomas
ah okay
This concerns transport issues
the need to reduce car usage especially
in our town by switching to active and
public transport is in your action plan
and the need for Action by Warwickshire
County Council and national government
is also in the action plan
but how is this being achieved
how are you influencing them so that it
takes place effectively and rapidly
if these plans cannot succeed without
residents changing their behavior and
I'm sure that's the case
how are you going to to promote that
change in Behavior
and again we're talking about public
engagement how will you share all of
these plans and their progress and
engage the community directly widely and
regularly I appreciate you you've
addressed that with Stephen Norris
question
but those are my principal points but I
just wanted to add if I may
um
back in January 21
Stephen who's just spoken put forward a
sustainable transport plan based on
modal modal change hubs
the panel was to consider this and
report back
I cannot find any reference to it in the
minutes of this panel or the cabinet or
four Council meetings
there's a lot of meetings to troll there
but I I couldn't find any mention of it
would you please come back about that
sustainable transport plan
um and later in May 22 Janet Palmer a
colleague in Stratford climate action
asked if there was a plan to keep cars
out of the Town Center Antrim to promote
park and ride
the response was basically to wait for
the South Warwickshire local plan and
local transport plans but surely this
will be too little too late already how
are we what do we
several years of this panel being an
existence and I it's perhaps just going
too slowly
it's the responsibility of the County
Council to provide transport
infrastructure
um
so will SDC Lobby the County Council
especially via SDC councilors that are
also County councilors to put in place
now
a bus only lane on the Birmingham road
instead of the two lanes proposed for
cars
then the parkway Park and Ride will
become more viable
and will this panel report regularly on
the progress of such lobbying please
I noted as a sort of uh after saw once
someone's bought a car
once you've purchased it it always it'll
become always the most convenient cheap
and comfortable means of getting about
so really in order to
uh
increase the the transfer to bus and and
car and and bike and foot
um
until the the purchase of cars has been
suppressed that that choice is always
going to be made I feel moving to cars
thank you
Dave did you have any comment to make on
that one
just on the first point that um
Mr Thomas raised about the
um presentation done by Mr Nori in
January 2021 I did um go back and take a
look at the minutes from that that
January 21 meeting and the minute say
that state that uh due to the complexity
of the question the panel would take it
away and look at look at outside of the
meeting
um so I I think Mr Thomas is right that
hasn't actually been a formal report
back from that but I think
um one of the ways that the um and I'm
given that Mr noise presentation at that
time was about active travel measures uh
measures to reduce cars in the town I
think there's a number of initiatives
which do appear in the climate change
Action Program which
has been our responding to the points
that are raised there so in in some ways
I think the council has sought to
respond to the points but I think Mr
Thomas is right that there hasn't been a
specific response to that that
presentation so it's just to provide
that that information but uh in in other
respects um
um that I I you know I haven't got
anything particular to add all right Mr
folks Skinner is on the call as well I
don't know um the weather uh as the
person that's sort of been leading a
number of Transport initiatives whether
you wanted to supplement on any of the
active travel measures
uh yes uh thank you Dave
um yeah just for those that don't know
me um I work within days climate change
team uh as a sustainable transport
project officer
um Mr Thomas is is correct I I believe
that we need to
cars off the road and and give people
the alternative and make it easy for
people to actually look at Alternatives
because you say once you've bought a car
um you like to use it
um so I've not been in the post onto
comment for
um 18 months and I've developing
relationships with the County Council
um we can influence the County Council
um I've got
um
various I'm talking to them about
various schemes we're talking about
potential
um
uh sort of all all bikes or bike higher
schemes
um I've got the e-cargo bike scheme that
I'm going to be talking about in a
little in a little while that I'm
working on I'm I'm working on behalf of
the Stratford district one of the things
I think is important especially for
Stratford is um
is the equity of Transport it's we need
to get
choices of Transport out of the towns
and into the more rural areas and how
it's not easy but we need to explore
that um whether that be
um uh carpool's uh car share carpooling
car clubs all that sort of stuff I would
like to explore
um
with the County Council and I am and
that's going to be one of my priorities
in the year we're in these two is to
start looking at that looking at
strategies to how we can bring in
um
car clubs I mean the evidence says that
if you want to influence people you do
it when they
they're going through a change anyway so
the idea that we can potentially uh Book
car clubs in our new developments that's
the time when people are going to change
their their habits when potentially when
they do a big move like a house move
um so I'm full of ideas I'm possibly
lacking in time
um but I'm Keen to work with the County
Council and and influence them as the
highway Authority in sustainable
transport
um
initiatives I'm happy to say if you've
got any further questions by always
email me and I can do my best to act as
a conduit may I may I just come back on
that I I agree the rural aspect is very
important but if we just go back to the
park and ride it's already there the car
Park's there the road is there we do
have buses
and and it's really not been it's not
been capitalized on
um and so I think that that you know
that's something easy that you could
start to do tomorrow you know we could
we could see the County Council because
it's their park and ride isn't it it's
there it's their car park yes that's for
a start off stop them selling any of it
um and and I would like to see evidence
that this this Council has spoken to
them about the Birmingham Road and a
different way of using it please
one of one of the things I I I've got at
Warwick District Council that I work
we've got a contract with a an
initiative called better points and we
work with the bus company we work with
Stagecoach and offer incentives for
people to use Stagecoach buses I mean
it'll be that's going up for
re-procurement next year and it'd be
great if Stratford come on board with
that because that's exactly what we
could encourage through
this sustainable travel initiative
called better points where you can we
can promote the use of that Park of life
for example through the idea is that if
you travel sustainably you get points
um for your miles that you take either
riding uh walking uh taking a bus taking
the train and you can swap those points
for uh money off local businesses so
it's an incentive scheme to actually get
people out of their cars and we can you
can geofence so if we wanted to
concentrate on that park and ride we
could geofence that and and offer uh
sort of incentives to people using that
park and ride
through this through an app if as if
Stratford wants to take it on we
certainly do it in white District where
we offer incentives for sustainable
travel
question for the time but I think with
the time being I would just urge action
and and speed
um years of passing by and every year
that goes by makes the subsequent years
even harder to deal with
us thank you
thank you
cancer unit yes I've just done that one
it's not it has to be made um Pleasant
um to be able to park your car there and
come in but also it's cheaper so for
example if it's cheaper at the park and
ride than it is to park in town uh but
you're right it has to be a nice Speedy
transfer uh whether that's using
Birmingham Road or another road in but
it has to be there has to be a speedy
transfer in rather than being sitting in
in a queue
um that negates the the reasoning or the
um they kind of um view of people using
a park and ride if they just kind of sit
on a bus and it's it's in in a traffic
jam but coming back to what I want to
say a lot a lot of the things that are
in the answer are in the hands of a
County Council but we do have some
Powers uh particularly on with them
planning
the other thing is about working with
County Council can Council and District
Council on on bids I know that for
example there was a bid put in for uh
looking at the High Street and Bridge
Street
um there was a bid it was initiated by
the Town Council but it was done through
the County Council I believe submitted
through the County Council and that
failed and the problem is these bid the
bidding system to government for funds
it's a bit of a lottery
um you know whether or not you will get
it and there needs to be a better way
perhaps that's something we need to
let people know on a relevant play
places
um particularly a place like Stratford
which is a tourist Hub
um which gets a lot of tourists maybe
that you know we're not count we're
counted on population at the moment
whereas if you count in the tourism
numbers then your actual figures using
those the facilities in the town are a
lot higher and we have to find a way of
getting that cross and the um
just just um you know investment is is
key planning as Kia I've just said uh
but when I've been abroad I've seen in
some countries uh Toronto but also in
New Zealand where you get bus hubs so
you get exchanges not just park and
rides but out in the rural areas where
you could leave a car and maybe get a
bus or a bus get into a in Toronto it's
things like ferries as well but you know
there has to be ways in which the
different types of travel have to be
exchanged and I think we could um as a
district council we could certainly put
our views forward on that
that's a good point to put forward so we
can we can take that on board and and go
ahead with that
so uh
is that your your questions complete now
uh I think so
um okay I just urge you know I know that
there may be changes you know
often but I hope all this passes on to
them okay
thank you very much
oh sorry Manuela sorry you were waiting
to come in I do apologize
um no yes I I mean obviously from all
the data that we that we have
commissioned we know the transport and
especially private car
um Private Car transport is the highest
um carbon emission uh cause in our in
our district because we are a rural
District
um follow followed by housing so what we
need in our rural areas and I represent
the rural world it's regular affordable
buses at the moment some of my residents
can't afford
um to take the bus because it's too
expensive to come to uh to Stratford
from for example
and my local bus number 27 is that the
service reduced
um so you know it's very difficult if
you have a GP appointment in town
um you know you need to wait for two
hours for the bus or wait two hours in
town so I think what is your County
Council or we as as the climate change
channel of self-distree council to
really really uh put pressure on board
your County Council
perhaps obviously working with graham to
um review that
um we also need this counselor Juliet
said um rural transport Hub interchanges
uh they're quite important and uh and
yes bustling's in town because then
um you know that that's a that's a way
of
um you know for residents who change
Behavior to do a a modal transport shift
because you don't want to be waiting in
the queues with the cars and and you
know that if you take the bus you'll be
arriving at your destination much
quicker
um so you know all these uh this we have
the power I think to to put pressure on
mortgage country Council and to Lobby
um for a better transport system for a
rural areas and I hope that
um the new administrations will do that
thank you
thank you very much
no other questions on this
no okay
thank you move on to the next speaker
then
foreign
hello
um my question is about the Town
Center's public bins strategy otherwise
known as the infrastructure
and it's in three parts
firstly is the apparent lack of
recycling bins in key areas in public
spaces
and the message this gives
overflowing bins and whether this is
exacerbated by the change in the waste
collections for General waste
and I'd like to also know the proportion
of rubbish
from public spaces in the town center
that is recycled
so in a bit more detail
um
what what I found particularly
concerning which which got me to look at
this topic further was the Bancroft
Gardens there's regularly overflowing
bins around there and I can't see any
recyclable waste
sorry recycling
facilities in in that area and it's
right by an area where you have lots of
public stalls it's very touristy people
bring picnics to the park
also it's um so not only is it a high
need area but it's also a very sensitive
area environmentally with the river and
waste flowing into the river
um I noticed that there didn't seem to
be recycling facilities publicly around
where you would expect them for example
outside
Corner shops and things like that you've
been outside the co-op in Trinity Mead
it's just a general waste bin and
it's often overflowing bringing me onto
my next topic these bins are of late
especially they appear to be overflowing
not only with things that could be
recycled but also with people who appear
to be packaging up their home waste
um
because possibly I'm suspecting because
they they're not happy about it having
to be collected on a three weekly basis
they might be smelly or getting maggots
things like that and people are just
dumping it in the bins
um and then I couldn't find any
information online to find a plan of
bins in the Town Center what type of
bins they are and any information on
What proportion of rubbish from these
public bins is recycled
um I did attach
um a guide which I I found it's it is
quite long it's about 78 pages I think
and it's by wrap I believe
um
and it does discuss various problems I I
got a suspicion that one of the issues
is contamination
a food packaging with with waste but
there are things you can do to overcome
that I also feel that maybe one of one
of the things that's been happening is
removal of bins
as opposed to to trying to overcome the
problems surrounding bin abuse or
contamination of recycling Etc but given
that lots of people here are tourists
and aren't able to take their rubbish
home might be staying in hotels I don't
think that's that's working or feasible
so that's the number of my question
okay thank you for that
um
I mean uh just looking at it from my
perspective because obviously uh waste
is is part of my portfolio and whatever
and
before I go back to these sort of
briefing note uh answers
the waste that's put into General waste
bins by members of the public
the guys do have a look it's not a very
nice job but they do have a look and if
there is any identifiable household
waste in them like if they can trace to
who put it there then they are working
to to uh to actually follow that up and
do something about it
um
the three-week waste collection
it's been in now since last August and
now we're at 99.86 efficiency on that
sort of working so I've got no worries
about the three-week waste waste
collections
um
always going to get bin abuse I mean
I'll leave it in in a rural patch and in
our local Village Hall we have a general
waste bin and people dumping that all
the time and and you know you see them
driving from houses to put stuff in
there it's not really just the people
that use the Village Hall so it's a it's
a sort of a district-wide problem
um but the uh
you know we've got uh recycling bins now
in Bridge Street three of them Bridge
foot we've got two Bridgeway we've got
one Chapel Street Church Street Henley
Street rather Street Waterside and Wood
Street so there is a fair few of them
about
um
and I think as as bins bins wear out I
mean it's all down to to uh just a
replacement they are being replaced with
split bins as far as I'm aware
um but I will check that out and make
sure that if that is the case then then
we make sure that we can pick out the
Recycled waste because we've got a very
good record in terms of our recycling
um numbers and we want to improve that
all the time so so from that perspective
we'll be uh we'll be doing something as
a council to make sure that that
situation improves
I got a question counselor Crump I think
sorry about my machine was playing up
there it was it was just a comment
really that um
maggots don't usually start appearing
until now that they usually die off the
Flyers are usually dying off
from the end of sept well it's probably
October November because of the climate
is changed when we start getting the
frosts having lived in the country All
My Life
um the maggots don't usually uh appear
they die off the flies that laid their
larvae and the muggers don't usually
start appearing until
the spring so I would be surprised if
there were markets currently around they
might be starting to appear but they
weren't repaired uh until recently and
because of the amount of sharp for us
we've had that would have curled the
Flies off
um so and this chair is OSU obviously
over in scrutiny committees is
scrutinized the one two three
um
contract uh and we've looked at the
figures and we're scrutinized several
times as you know Mr chairman you've
been to that meeting
um required to come to a meeting and and
the uh questioned on that so I think uh
the points about recycling uh I think
residual waste is obviously reduced by I
think it was 30 hasn't it and uh
recycling has increased by 15 to 20 so I
think we've just got a get the big wins
in first make the most difference and
then potentially concentrate on areas
where we can make a difference but let's
get the big wins in first make the most
difference and therefore there are other
areas to go into that's fine but your
point about contamination particularly
by dog walkers as a dog walker myself I
see it in my tone
um people putting dog waste in
in recycling bins which is which is not
present so I can imagine the the
contamination isn't great but I think we
do need to concentrate on the big wins
and then see how we can move these
things forward as well
thank you
cargo
thanks Shannon I think there's an issue
here if I cast my mind back at some
point I remember talk it was talk about
using smart recycling waste bins
um so that they can be pulled you know
emptied and until I quite on demand so
to speak which would hopefully solve one
problem the other one is that we've
experienced it this is where we separate
out residual waste and waste from
properties with General waste in the
towns for example because
um I know we've had some problems and
I've reported this uh with regards to
the waste collection
and I know that the the team are working
on that but so the household waste is
very good but we have had issues with
bins and such like around the towns and
such right so I wonder whether there's a
there's an issue here we can actually
bring the two together and that would be
smart bins which tell us when they're
full or getting full and then perhaps we
can actually get these things emptied in
the in the cook away now I don't know if
those smart bins are ever taken forward
so I I just don't know but it was it was
mooted at one point
okay thank you for that I know that uh
the frequency is regularly viewed I mean
I was talking to the head of service
about this last week and uh they're
reviewing the uh the collection and
emptying periods of each bin and so
whether that's going to affect the
future and how things move forward
because I think that's only been in
place for a couple of weeks now so we'll
see how that sort of bears fruit if at
all and and work forward from there but
it's constantly been reviewed if things
are getting full too quickly they're
getting emptied quicker so that's all I
can say at the moment
uh Graham wants to come in as well I
think
yes thank you um my substantive post
um back at Warwick District Council was
with the um Boston recycling team and I
can't speak but now um and I can't speak
for the current contract but I wasn't
involved in the in our old voice and
recycling contract which work had with
um a sewers and
you're absolutely right I mean the we
had split we we have had split bins
where you have a single and I have a
public bin that's got
um refugees on one side or landfill
waste on one and then the other half is
in theories recycling
we have done that we've worked with it
but what we we did find
um was is what everybody else is alluded
to is the contamination side of it is is
that people you need really clear
messages
um and some inventive ways of doing it
um you can get you can get companies out
there that can offer you really quite
um
uh
um funny ways of of getting people to
recycle in this uh quite unique ways
strategies because otherwise people
don't know what's goes in them and
people are inherently lazy and they just
put stuff they just put anything in any
bin and that's what we've found
unfortunately with Sue is is that we
were collecting that recycling but it
was so badly contaminated that we
couldn't you couldn't take it from
recycling just couldn't do it because
the likes of dog waste and food waste
and all that sort of stuff so it's
incredibly difficult
um to you know to get that message of
course about what goes where
um and
the other thing the the speaker
mentioned was household waste next to
public bins
um what again I'm talking going back to
my time at Warwick what we did urge was
that obviously for some reason that
their domestic waste collections aren't
working
um and what we were able to do at
Warwick is that if if they ring up they
run us up
we could talk through why they were
struggling I mean it could be capacity
it could be lack of information so I
would urge anybody that is struggling
with capacity especially on this on on
now with with three weekly is to is to
talk to the council because they're in
theory there is a huge amount of
recycling offered and there shouldn't be
a great deal going into residual waste I
mean there's this lap is uh
nappy side of things but the rest of it
should be recyclable so if I would urge
somebody that is struggling like that to
get in contact with Stratford or the or
the combined team because there should
be a solution to that
so I got off my soapbox thank you
okay thank you does that answer you oh
sorry cancer Junior
I used to work in the waste industry
mainly on the commercial waste side uh
and I did pilot projects all across the
country working with councils
um and one of them was uh recycling it
was in London though where the the
volume was much much bigger so that it
was easier to handle from that point of
view but what
um I worked very closely with rap and
one of my team then went on to work with
rap and I think the you know it was I
was reminded by the um the the leaflet
that was uh with this question uh about
about rap and we it's just maybe because
they've got a lot of expertise but
they've also got a lot of information
they can give to uh to the public so we
just need to be able to check that we're
using maximizing the use of their their
information to the to the full extent
they've got a lot of a lot of I I know
our team here already knows that
um the people in the waste and recycling
but you know it's just a message that
rapper I do have a lot of resources
ah shall let the speaker go first and
then cancel the Crump
I'd just like to know what the
proportion of waste in public bins is
currently recycled and I would like
um if there is information like this a
map of the bins so I can see where they
are because I I walked around I couldn't
see one around Bancroft Gardens and
that's where there's a lot of recyclable
waste
and so my feeling is that although we're
talking about the success of the new
waste collections there's been a lot of
focus on that in the answers what I'm
trying to say is that maybe the current
infrastructure isn't
sufficient for the needs of the Town
especially with all the food markets now
maybe it needs to change to accommodate
the changes in in what's happening in
the town
plus I'm just saying that it's
exacerbated possibly by the public bin
issue I'm aware that the maggots haven't
started yet but for example if someone
misses one of their collections they
then have a six week wait and if you
look on the public social media forums
there are lots of complaints about
overflowing bins and local councilors
offering to take this issue on so it is
something that it's not just me
imagining this there is it is being
documented and raised by other people so
if I if if I could have these statistics
and and see where the bins are and maybe
I could then
using that information come back and
rediscuss this at a later date
okay well the two questions that you
just mentioned about bin maps and
whatever we'll take that to officers
excuse me
and uh and then we'll we'll come back to
you on that that's that's the the first
way to do it to get from the right
information from the right people and
we're from recycling bins
are they similarly taking out obviously
recyclable waste from the general bins
and recycling it or does it all just go
to landfill
got a question I'll come back to you on
that
yeah I I think he's trying to enhance
the minds really is encouraging people
um
to reduce as much as possible you know
I've I wasn't mentioning something on on
my Facebook pages locally where I am uh
and uh
and the card with some several comments
from people oh you're not one of these
one team believe that all this carbon uh
Guff that's that was their word about
mine on total opposition to what I say
and some of these people take perverse
pleasure in actually putting uh things
in the wrong bin on purpose and
contaminating them and you know I find
that extremely sad so again we need to
spread the message and get the word over
that that isn't right but
um so yeah it is and personally would I
like to keep on put fishing my hand in
in some of these bins to move these
across I I think that the people who do
that do an extremely good job and
extremely challenging circumstances so I
I said my
um thanks to those as well I think that
should be noted as well thank you
oh sorry we've gone as far as we can
with this now so uh we take those
questions that you made at the end about
Collective bins and whatever and and
we'll get answers to those questions
thank you
yeah we've got another question in from
Jenny loins
um does anybody on the panel want to
comment on that question
yeah cancer journeyed
I don't own a housing
[Music]
housing closely with housing
associations as well we also have the
ability to require
developers in planning to um to to come
up to certain standards and and it is
worth remembering
um that although the false technical
specification on the future home
standard will has not yet been issued it
will be issued in 2023 after a
considerable delay with the legislation
in 2024 and implementation in 2025
there are still there are significant
limitations to that future home
standards and this occurs across whether
it's housing associations or new build
that whether they're being you know
built or refitted
um and um
I could go into the details but I I
won't but both the Tran Town cams Town
and Country planning Authority and the
Royal town planning Institute and others
within the field all believe that local
planning authorities in England are able
to set standards above the building
regulatory minute minimum and that is
key to our local plan if we've got it in
the local plan then developers can't
challenge it but we are allowed to go
beyond the building minimum standards
and you know we we should make sure that
we do so
we can pass that information through to
our applying department and and see
where they go from there to be part of
the local plan it has to be yeah
absolutely
now right uh we have to move on to item
five on the agenda update on tree call
to action project from heart of England
Forest to receive an update from Chloe
Edwards of Heart of England Forest
regarding the trees call to action
project
okay does that work
yes
um brilliant so Howard I think has some
slides which we'll just load up and then
I'll be able to give you an update on
the trees call to action fun project
thanks
that's all right don't worry
thank you
lovely job okay great
um so thank you for inviting me to speak
today
um on behalf of the trees call to action
fun project my name is Chloe I'm the
project project manager and it's
important to know that this is a
partnership project so whilst I'm based
on work at the heart of England Forest
this is a project that was written and
is being delivered by all four Partners
so it's a Harlingen Forest charity and
the District councils of Stratford Navan
Warwick and witchhaven
so where does the funding for the
project come from
um next slide please Howard
there we go so we are funded through the
nature for climate funds so within the
nature for climate fund is the England
trees action plan which has the
objectives to treble the tree planting
rates in England and in order to get
that done the they have created the
trees call to action fund which required
people to bid to the project and outline
what they would do and how they would do
it the idea is to build capacity for
tree planting and create Partnerships
between organizations
so
um the the project Partners I've
mentioned is Stratford Warwick which
Haven harvington Forest and together
we've written a bid that's brought over
499 000 pounds to the project area which
is a huge amount of money to create
resource for tree planting and changes
across our district
um the logo at the top here shows that
the project is funded by the tree's call
to action fund and that fund was
developed by defra in partnership with
the forestry commission and is being
delivered by the Heritage fund
okay next slide please
lovely
um so this here is how to describe why
we're delivering the project so I think
it's important to give you all the
ambition the the intention that we have
um so the tree's call to action project
is responding to the significant climate
biodiversity crises that we Face
recognizing that the best approach is
collaborative and joined up working and
this is with Our intention with our
project is to inspire tree planting
action finding Solutions together and
working across the landscape and overall
the project will expand trees and
Woodland coverage in order to benefit
the environment communities create
employment opportunities and connect
people with nature and overall develop a
wider understanding of the importance of
trees with giving people the skills and
knowledge
that will enable people to look after
them and expand this in the future as
well
so that brings us on to the next slide
great so as I've mentioned I'm based at
the heartwingham forest so this is we've
done sort of why was the project
happening this is where are we and the
map here that hopefully everyone can see
um is showing the project outlines that
covers which Haven District Warwick and
Stratford and the green circles indicate
where the heart of England Forest areas
are at the moment
um so this has brought 499 000 pounds to
the region
um and I think it's relevant to say that
we're the reason we're based as a team
at the heart of England Forest is to
draw on that tree planting experience
from the past 20 years that they've
developed
um the harvington forest itself is the
largest new native broadly forest in the
country
um and it's right on the doorstep of
Stratford on Avon it's currently stands
over 7 000 acres and is a in my mind a
National Asset to the region and the
tree planting activity that's taking
place there is contributing
significantly to The Climate Ambitions
of Stratford District Council
um I'm really pleased that we've been
able to work in a collaborative way to
to bring that expertise together with
the influence of the district council
across this area
and it shows a really forward-thinking
approach from Stratford I think
um to to kind of work on a collaborative
approach like this
so next slide brings us on to what are
we doing we've done why where this is
what
um our objectives are to help
communities and landowners to expand and
connect trees and Woodlands making those
trees and Woodlands part of a green
economy and connecting people to them as
well so there's the lovely delivery team
top right including myself and the Three
Delivery officers the delivery officers
will be contacting the over 200 Parish
councils that are across the project
area and they're going to be supporting
those those people and landowners to
identify suitable places for tree
planting sourcing grants and then
getting it done
so a recent examples where we've worked
with great on Parish Council who had
done an amazing job of collecting what
they needed to be able to do the
planting so they had the trees Stakes
things that they needed but we were able
to build confidence in their planting
plan by working on the design with them
in the lead-up to the planting and being
able to map out what we would put where
considering things like utilities and
giving the community that kind of
confidence to go into their plan and
make it happen
and hopefully that's going to help
overcome a lot of those hurdles for
Community groups who might feel unsure
otherwise
by 2025 we will have worked with a
hundred communities in this way and 50
landowners to support planting plans for
trees Orchards Hedges and
363 hectares of new Woodland
um which is going to be a really
significant amount to bring to this this
area
so that brings me on to the next slide
so I just want to talk about the
approach that we take when we're doing
this so we want to expand and connect
the trees and woodlands and many people
might have heard of this idea of the
right trees in the right place for the
right reason so how are we doing that so
when we meet with our communities and
landowners we help them design planting
plans
um in the corner you can see some images
they're small but the the idea
replicates we're always looking at a lot
of the data layers that exist online and
this one in particular is looking at
groundwater flooding and historic flood
records
these are one of the many many types of
data that we consider when we're doing a
desktop assessment of people's sites so
this helps people identify and feel
confident about why they're planting
what they're planting and where so
species mixes flooding
various utility searches go on to make
sure they're in the right place
as far as possible we recommend native
species suited to the landscape
characteristics and we use Forest
research software and data to make sure
that that's what we're doing we also
look at local Authority strategies and
ecological Maps so those really
influence what we look to plant where
and as I've mentioned already in total
that the 363 new hectares will be
planned for 2025 and we also have
stretch targets to look into the future
and create a strategy for planting up to
3620 hectares by 2050
and that's across the project area
so that brings me on to the next of the
two objects of the three objectives in
total
and so our other objectives center
around the power of people on this
project so trees and Woodlands forming
part of the green economy that has been
um kind of inaction already by hiring my
lovely team and so myself the Three
Delivery officers and we've also
recruited four forestry apprentices and
by doing this we're creating in your
local area a group of people who will
have the skills and capacity to continue
to lead projects like this and manage
and look after the trees as we go into
the future if we haven't got
infrastructure for people to manage in
the future then we're setting up for
failure so it's really important that
we're focusing on teaching skills
and that's why we're also looking to
teach skills to the community
and within the project structure that
was written by Stratford and partners we
have planned to deliver skills to 500
volunteers across Community areas and
we've already empowered over 120 of the
target 500 and that will teach people
not only the skills to plant trees but
also maintenance and so in the bottom
left you can see a picture from the vale
landscape Heritage Trust where we were
running an orchard maintenance day and
those have gone down very very well so
we'll continue to run skills on
maintenance as well
okay that brings me on
to the next slide
um which is the role that Stratford
District Council is playing in this
project and the importance that is
attached to this so
um I'm really very pleased that
Stratford has been a Partners to use
this as a key strategic tool to improve
the district
and this introduction of new trees and
also the maintenance of existing trees
will help the district adapt to climate
change and we can see that the benefits
include things like carbon sequestration
cooling effects on urban areas natural
flood management improve air quality
things that a lot of people are aware of
but these will be being delivered
through the project
um and that it relates to ambition three
on your climate change Ambitions so
that's to enable our environment and
communities to have adapted
um to the likelihood of a Three Degree
uh increase in temperature across the
area by 2100 so that's the kind of focus
of this project uh locally
and the next slide I want to tell you
what we have actually done already
instead of just talking about what I'm
trying to do uh so in the past six
months across Stratford District we have
already planted over 127 000 new trees
which comes out as over 220 Acres or if
you work in hectares it's over 90
hectares and those are new trees and
woodlands in Stratford District
um which is I'm really really proud of
this being achieved on top of that we've
also taught 113 new volunteers the
skills to plant and care for trees and
obviously that's what we're going to
continue to do throughout the project
so we have got two more years left
um and we've only been going for uh six
months in terms of delivery of the
project
so what we're going to continue to do
where we have begun contacting parish
councils and landowners across the
district we're going to carry on
reaching out to those groups of people
over the next two years to build the
momentum within the project and continue
to deliver on tree planting and
volunteer skills
um so my final slide
brings us to what I can ask of others uh
to help with the project and build this
momentum
um as we go through the next two years
so I leave you with three actions that
you could take to make a difference
if you were part of a community group
you could look for areas that might
benefit from trees and contact us to
discuss a planting plan you don't have
to be sure that they can take them but
we can come and visit you
and if you have any management control
of private and we want to help you
benefit from trees as well so there is
options to private and public land
through our project
again we can come and look at the space
to help you understand your options and
finally if you don't have access to land
you can still volunteer with us to learn
the skills and learn more about how to
protect trees going into the future
because of all of those benefits that
they hold for us all
and I've attached my website and my
email address there
um but you can find us Googling trees
call to action project and it comes up
through the heart finger forest website
and obviously Stratford is a key partner
on our project as well thank you
thank you very much for that
presentation and Susan uh yeah just a
couple of things one one you've answered
my question on the last slide at who's
to get in touch with we've got an idea
of a piece of London I do so I I'll get
in touch with yourself that that's
correct isn't it through the email that
was on that last slide and I'm working
currently with a a group of um people
that is doing Environmental Education
um in Ulster with with the young people
is that something I could also talk to
you about
um or somebody else in your team yeah so
um given I've put mine up there I can
take any contacts and I can direct them
appropriately and we'd love to hear
about collaboration if we can do it we
will if there are ways that um we can't
support and collaboration then we'll let
you know why and give you reasons for
that as well and finally do you work
with the Warrington Wildlife trust as
well
um so we have got some contacts with
work to Wildlife trust and but we'll be
developing them over the next two years
um so we haven't got projects planned
with them at the moment
thank you very much
sorry
ah
cancer put together you want to come in
yeah thank you Chloe for the
presentation
um can I ask how do you identify parish
councils and Community groups to come on
board could you tell us if you have some
criteria or the groups that you worked
with the parishance you work with until
now thank you
yeah no worries
um so at the start of the project we
mapped every Parish Council across the
three districts and and we will be
contacting all of them the way that we
initiate contacts through email with the
project details and we follow up on that
and we give multiple opportunities for
parishes to respond to us
um people don't need to continue that by
email what people tend to then do is
invite us to speak to them in person to
visit their sites and that's how we
operate that way and our our list of who
we contact First tends to be based on
what we've found about their activities
online and we map according to what we
can see as being interest to build
momentum quickly through the project and
then we want to try and create case
studies to continue to build that
momentum with parishes who might not
have previously taken up activities like
this
okay thank you very much
oh gray I'm sorry I keep missing these
let's look well thank you Chloe for the
presentation I mean uh
councilor Juniors partly asked the same
question I was going to ask is that and
you've answered it in the sense that
you're not necessarily working in
isolation with these
with his tree planting schemes and
you're talking about uh working with the
wildlife trust well I was just thinking
if you if because there's going to be
other other organizations planting trees
I mean it'd be really useful if you
could to produce corridors Wildlife
corridors between groups of tree
planting so you you get rather than just
isolated pockets you actually get um
some form of wildlife Corridor between
between these developments or between
these um programs and I think you've
already answered the question I think
you are planning to work with the
wildlife trusts and I guess anybody else
that is also planting trees
yes it's sorry it's that okay to come
back on
any no no other questions
yeah
thank you yeah you as well
um yes that shouldn't be a problem um it
may have some of my notes in so that
might be the only thing that's fine
thank you
so Manuela and Christian didn't hear
that we will um share the slides after
the meeting
thank you Chloe that's really good and a
lot of interest in that so I look
forward to working with you I mean
on the Paris Council chairman in bidford
so we're not that far away from Euro so
so we're very familiar with what goes on
there and uh and thank you very much for
coming in and doing the presentation
thank you
move on to item six on the agenda which
is update on the cargo bike scheme
I'm assuming that's going to be Graham
yes
it is it is me um just bear with me I've
never done this before so if it I'm
hopefully going to share my my screen
um
but I know how it's got a set of my
slides in case I fail miserably
okay can that be seen
I'm kind of here
no problem okay from here Graham good
I'll thankfully put on a
slide
here we go hopefully that's a
presentation mode all being well
um
yes thank you uh thank you councilor
together for giving me the opportunity
to
um
talk about it I
well as I said before early in the
meeting I worked for Warwick District
Council but when I was uh seconded onto
the current role I was asked to
to look after the this initiative which
is a Stratford District Council
initiative
um
so
this phase summary
um back in June 21 Stratford applied to
the energy saving trust for grant
funding of sixty thousand pounds which
Stratford District matched with a
further 60 000 pound for a five-year
relationship with the local bike
builders partially
um
so I I wasn't involved at the time so
that was done just before I started
um we received the grant funding in
March 22 and the 60 000 pound
um paid for 10 bikes uh five uh eight
bikes uh five E trikes five
um normal normal two-wheel bikes
um it also paid for a storage facility
and trailing at the past the office
stroke Depot at Masons Avenue and also
the support
um so if a business takes on one of
these bikes
um
they have the support of Stratford by
caring because you can't just spend the
punch on one of these bikes it's not
that so you can't just turn it upside
down and it's handlebars and mend a
puncher so that you do you do need that
um that support
um the one thing that I added to uh and
and asked for the pushing to spend was
um tracking devices on the bikes just
for from a theft point of view but
mainly I did it from uh
um
a mileage so that you know how many
miles they've done and then we can
equate those miles to um
uh CO2 emissions saved if if we wanted
to go down that route so we all the
bikes are tracked and we can see how
many miles they've done
um I was involved in the formal launch
which was in April 22.
and
that's probably a bit tidy for you to
read but we basically put a a press
release out and then we did a whole load
of publicity on on the launch
um
who's pretty much swamped the local
media
um we yeah I I worked with um the media
person within the Stratford district and
we we did all the um
all the local papers
um the local community newsletters and
we produced our own publicity within
flyers and pull-ups and we did our best
to to sell the scheme
um
we
at the launch we launched it formally in
Stratford Town Center but then I went
out to every main town in the district I
pre I publicized it beforehand so I went
out and settler is coming and spoke to
whether it be the comparison of the Town
Council and said I'm on my way
um so yes I I I I went out there and
went to supermarkets and outside Village
halls and
um in town in Village centers and what
have you and and try to sell
um the idea of of these bikes
um
post launch we got a fair a fair amount
of Interest we we got letters of support
and we got a large amount of initial
interest just sorry I haven't really
summarize this
um the scheme itself basically it was
it's designed for businesses within
Stratford District to borrow a bike so
effectively they can borrow a bike
um
um for three months or more
um it it it's relative it doesn't cost
anything to do yet they do need to cover
the insurance but it doesn't cost
anything
um and they it's for them to to file it
out just to see how a bike an e-bike
would work
um so we have we've we had a lot of
initial interest
um both self-employed uh people and the
larger companies larger organizations
within the district
um but that initial interest is has not
um translated into actual usage
um and most of the bikes unfortunately
are still sitting within the
uh the storage facility at pashley
[Music]
um
oh I'm exploring why uh it it it isn't
necessarily easy to pin down by the
initial interest didn't actually move
into actual usage
um
there are a few requirements that we
asked for
um uh they've got they've got to be
stored overnight
um in in some way that's secure which
is obvious I mean that's obvious really
because they're reasonably expensive for
bikes and most I don't think that is
particularly a hindrance
what potentially could be a hindrance is
that we we cover or Stratford cover the
theft and the Damage side of the bike
but we do ask for public liability of 2
million
um and
I am exploring whether that is a
hindrance to people taking it on
um and I'm speaking to
are in short my insurance colleague at
Stratford to see whether or not it is
possible that Stratford take on
that liability and that liability
insurance and then any interested
business would then pay a certain amount
um to cover that insurance so they we've
got it but the the business pays into it
we ask for a signed contract which is I
mean that's fairly standard
um we asked that the bikes are returned
and collected from The partially uh
Factory at some
Mason's Road
um
and that's largely it I mean I it it's
got a lot of potential and it's to my
mind it's a real shame that most of them
are not
being used
um we we plan
um to relaunch it in the spring we we
are gonna I'm gonna work
um with my colleagues
um and the media and have another
relaunch of it possibly with
um
the insurance covered by Stratford
Stratford District I am part of
um
I am part of um
National forums um and the energy saving
trust have
um
they have a disc we've had discussions
around because there's obviously more
than just ask our Council that have have
taken the grants on and it is a slow
burn it
they were saying to me don't be
discouraged the fact you've got low low
take up in in the year that we're in
because it will take a while
um I'm hopefully won't say too much of
more of a while but I mean it it it it
is something that uh needs to get in
people's Consciousness and one of the
things that we are
doing with the current bike that's out
there is putting an advert on the side
of the thing saying look do you know you
can have this for free if you want it um
so and that is out regularly
um the one that is being used is you've
been used well so if we hopefully we get
a bit of momentum behind it we advertise
it
um possibly offer a simpler way of
ensuring them things
um I'm hoping that we get a more more
pickup but
um councilor together please you also
the presentation I would love your views
on it and and and anybody else's views
as to how you feel
we could get this out and about in The
District more I I was actually yeah
going to ask her what we working with
West counselors to really promote these
I mean I I got like a couple of shops in
my Village uh where I live so and I
think it would be really even if you're
in a rural Village I think it'll be
really good because they do have
deliveries and so on so
um and and I I think the insurance might
be a barrier but I'm disappointed to her
that hasn't been taken on and I and you
know I think is is a really good scheme
and I
um you know what can we do actually to
to promote it to our small businesses
you know
um and if there is anything that we can
do if we need to do Road shows again
um you know please because I I think
um it's it's really a scheme that it's
worth doing and also it was part of our
strategy to decarbonize you know the
kind of
um uh in in a way to have you know elect
vehicles for for commercial deliveries
and so on so
um yeah I mean yeah I mean I hope to to
sorry that we can that we can promote it
and relaunch it with um you know
um renewed
um enthusiasm and energy and see if we
can make it work yes I wonder as well if
sorry sorry game I wonder whether we
could ask our public as well uh whether
they have any ideas on how to make this
work
um our our residents but also our
um public sitting in our in the chambers
today yes
the members are probably the vast asked
the questions so far
yeah all day it was are they aware of it
I mean that's the thing I mean perhaps
we're we're not it's not out there as
much as it should be I mean the
insurance the person that is using it
currently
they just went on a on a comparison site
and got it relatively cheaply so the
insurance isn't necessarily all that
much of a barrier
um
they it may be a bit intimidating I mean
that they are different the bikes are
they're not a normal bite and then we do
offer the awareness training for the use
of them
um we've gone down the list we have we
contacted all the person all the
companies that were initially interested
and for one the RSC
um has come back so yeah we are
definitely interested but we haven't got
around to it so I think people show an
interest but then so many other things
get in the way that they they lose they
lose the idea again so they I sort of a
routine reminder of those that were
interested I think will help um just to
say look just Badger them politely and
say look you did show an initial
interest are you still interested um
because there's some good sites I mean
for example University of Warwick at
wellsborn campus they wanted one and you
can see it working really well there
um the other option I was considering is
using it internally
um
potentially I mean I know it's not
strictly business but if they're there
not being used sitting in the shipping
container why don't we get the Civil
Enforcement Officers out there using
them or
we can't use the beep we can't use them
for bin collection not bins early on
perhaps we can go around recycling the
public bins like but things things that
we could in the staff could use possibly
and get the get get it out there get it
out there and be being seen that and
hopefully that will trigger more
interest if we get um more bikes out
there but
yeah I'll be over to the members of the
public like Stephen norion what have you
that
are you aware of them
oh thanks
yeah I mean it sounds like you're doing
the research and and you you have an
idea that there is a it is a viable
scheme in terms of you know company
needs and so on so I don't have anything
to to offer on that I just say you know
if you're talking to people you know try
to go and meet them try and you know get
people to to try them out or you know
just send in the odd email you know
people people get lots of emails so just
yeah you may have to drive the door to
do a Salesman technique
be my input on this but uh yeah it
sounds like keep going and maybe you'll
get there
yeah I mean we could turn up at the
doors couldn't we were the with the van
with a bike and say and we're not going
to go away until you've you want until
you borrow one but no I mean you're
right I mean actually emails are very
easy to dismiss I mean the road shows
we did get interest at the road shows um
but equally
not as much as I thought we'd get
um and getting them out there uh more
more events I mean for example Earth Day
this Saturday they were at Bedford for
example with an event that bidford held
um and if you as counselors if you know
of any
Bates
whatever let let us know I mean there's
any events going on in your in your
areas that we I mean we can ball out
with a bike or we could even cycle it
out I mean it's we could get them out to
public events that are held within your
within your Awards um please let us know
that's one option is that we get we get
them out to and we can publicize them at
um local events
okay thank you very much for that I've
got a couple other people want to speak
canceled unit
yes I just I want I wondered whether
you'd be able to do any comparison to
other areas where they have reused the
bikes and whether or not there are any
lessons to be learned and whether for
example whether they work better in
areas
towns or cities that have got restricted
traffic not exactly pedestrianization
but near progesteronization where
um that you know there isn't the heavy
good vehicles and and because it could
be quite intimidating I mean trying to
ride one of these bikes down Birmingham
Road for example when there's lorries
and and coaches and buses coming in
could be quite intimidating so I'm just
wondering are there particular
circumstances that you've come across or
the energy saving trust has come across
where they are more likely to work and
could we learn from them
yes I mean they do work better in in
larger places which have got that
infrastructure so you're talking
Manchester you're talking London where
they've got those bite line bite lanes
they've they've the connectivity I mean
the thing with Stratford is that you've
got pockets of population
um so shipston for example you if you
you couldn't necessarily
deliver your pizza from shipston to
somewhere else or Halford for example or
whatever it may be
because you you anything people that
want to use it in Shepstone for example
um the uh
they will be stuck to that so it works
better when you've got certainly got the
infrastructure and you're right I mean
you you it could be slightly
intimidating if you if you haven't got a
cyclone to go down
um and equally if if in an urban area
where you've got
um it it is largely quicker to
um
go by them is by by car so
yes I mean there are there are examples
where it is working but it is largely in
in bigger areas that um have got the
infrastructure and perhaps that's
something we could feed back to with the
County Council when they are putting
forward further bids for for example to
do work on Bridge Street High Street or
whatever in Stratford or any other area
yes that this might the work they do
might favor the use of these kind of
bikes if they were to do it or to win
the bids
the other thing that I'm working with
the one of the relationships I'm working
with the county about is contacting
pharmacies
and prescription deliveries and that's
another option that I've got up my
sleeve is to try and get them out to
local pharmacies within Stratford and
um potential Care Homes if you've got
care workers that are traveling locally
yeah so I I have there is a number of
initiatives up my sleeve um I just need
to
get on with it
thank you very much for that Graham I've
got three people want to speak uh okay
cancer cargo was first in
yeah I think Grandma actually answered
do you deliver them that's the question
so for example if we do want one server
and Ulster deliver it uh no but I mean
that may be another barrier in that we
know we do ask them to be collected and
um uh uh returned to Mason's to Mason's
Road the pashi site I mean if that's a
hindrance I'm sure we can get around it
so if we get to that point with a
council or business I'm sure there'll be
ways around that
um
I just don't fancy cycling it down the
a46 that's all can I just check
councilor cargo were you um meaning for
um to do a promotional event because we
have delivered it yes the promotional
events we we do do delivery so it can
sort of uh yeah sorry yeah yeah it was
amazing I thought it was across across
purpose there going on yeah yeah
but yeah okay well yeah I'll look into
that one with you yeah sorry we with the
with the um
the promotions yeah we've I've borrowed
passion's van so we we can get them out
there to publicize them absolutely
well I've got a I've got an event coming
up in Austin not too distant uh it's
called the coronation and one of the
things I'm just thinking of an
advertising campaign is we also do uh
litig collections for you know around
down the High Street it'd be quite cool
to actually just drive it down there
picking up the litter and things like
that I'm just thinking of promotion for
approaching it for you that's all yeah
they do have the food festival uh
councilor Cargill where that word might
fit in because Leisure freonster does
that as well so it might be something we
could explore
yeah it's it it we have issues because
it's a small High Street and it's quite
packed but let's look into it
because what what you could do as a as a
as a council is you could you could
borrow one as a council and then lend it
out
to whoever would be interested in
lending it out so that's but that's
another model is that you could you
could you could have one as the council
and then keep it somewhere safe and then
lend it out to interested parties
whether it be volunteer litter Pickers
or whatever it may be
that one with me we'll have a look at
that one thank you thank you okay thank
you I've got two more speakers Michelle
would like to come in and then cancel
the put together
thank you
um I would say
um definitely uh barriers to take up are
going to be the requirement to get the
insurance
and
the collection from from the warehouse
it just it is going to be a barrier in
reality
um I was wondering is it possible if you
did an event say to cover well had them
on display say at Bell Court you had
clear signage leaflets about how it
works people could sign up there and
then are they able to take the bike
there and then as well or is there a
delay some sort of process because if
people can do things there and then and
then they've got the bike
that would be really beneficial
um also in terms of advertising I would
say that social media the the forums the
local groups next door things like that
are going to be really useful
um also I was wondering about
um
having a display of them and some
information maybe at great big green
week
um also in our monthly repair cafes
they're now going to be at the Methodist
Church you could even have them outside
or now you know now we've got space
um you could incorporate that can I just
say we don't really want to be getting
into five or six different options it's
just a brief thing to throw some ideas
out there okay thank you
okay thank you
can support together
thank you so much Michelle because these
are really good ideas and I I was
thinking about the repair Cafe as well
um so hopefully we'll uh we we can do
that we can organize a um you know any
cargo bike or trucks down there
um there's a very
um large Green Day organizing Junior and
there's quite a lot of businesses in
milanvale
um you know that you that would benefit
so I'm gonna put you in contact with the
organizers and then we'll see whether we
can get we can get some bikes up there
and see whether
um they you know just to raise awareness
and that that's in June I think so I'll
I'll do that very soon thank you
yeah thank you very much and thank you
for the suggestions I mean the
unfortunately just as much as I would
like to just give them away on the the
day there is a small amount of paperwork
to fill in um and we do need proof of
insurance and stuff like that so
as much as it'd be lovely to just sort
of give them away on the day that we're
promoting them we there is a bit of it's
not complicated but we do need to
protect ourselves with regards to
insurance and making sure that you that
you're you can you heard awareness
training and stuff like that so but
thank you for your suggestions it's
really helpful
thank you Graeme thank you um
right uh is that all you've got to say
on it now gray we can move to the next
point
yes it is thank you okay thank you
um right move on to item seven on the
agenda
the summary of key recent International
and National Climate Change Publications
I think
Dave's provided a report for this do you
want to lead up on that Dave
yes thank you I don't think I need to
say too much by way of introduction
um I mean the going over the last couple
of years we've prepared a number of
these reports and particularly in the uh
well not to cop26 in Glasgow
um there were a lot of national
announcements that uh we kept the panel
up to date with
um things were a little bit quieter but
um towards the end of March was a little
flurry of um of reports I thought might
be
um interesting context for the work that
we're doing locally
um and that range from the
um International work of the ipcc so
that's the intergovernmental panel on
climate change uh which is uh you know
highly scientific report which I have
um sort of synthesized in the report
into a number of
um sort of headings I've done that by
simply using the um
ipcc's ipcc's
um uh PowerPoint slides which they have
used to present their report for those
of a scientific mind I would really
recommend reading the report there's
lots and lots of
um loads more detail in there and
um and and in fact even for those of
non-scientific mind there is a
um a a summary for for policy makers as
well it is aimed mainly at um
governments as the name suggests uh but
certainly interesting context for us in
terms of the
um difficulties that we're facing
globally
um around climate change some of the big
risks that we have coming up but also
the uh the the sort of Hope and the the
path forward is set out with that in
that report as well so really really
useful context for us as well uh for for
us locally I think
um coming down to um the UK level
the um UK Parliament climate change
committee
um prepared uh a report on the progress
on adapting to climate change in March
as well
um and again I've summarized that by
cutting and pasting directly from that
report so there's no interpretation from
me and this is just what they've
highlighted in the report so the three
three key messages from that are about
um you know the need
um
the need to do more that they actually
are our national adaptation program
isn't adequately preparing the UK for
climate change yet
um the impacts of extreme weather in the
UK over the last year and particularly I
guess this is referring to the um
drought and uh heat waves of last summer
uh really highlight that urgency to
address it so we are seeing the changes
in where the pattern's taking place now
um and the next national adaptation
program
um really needs which is good to be
published in 2023 uh really does need to
make that step change so that's the
recommendations from the climate change
committee to the UK Parliament
um and clearly climate change committee
are made up of a panel of experts who
have been looking into this over a
period of time
um if you want to delve into more detail
of some very colorful diagrams which
show the areas which are of particular
progress or particular concern and it's
it's it's interesting to note some of
those and I'm very happy to sort of um
interpret some of those uh colorful but
slightly complex diagrams if if if
needed the final report is the UK
government's report on powering up
Britain which is very much about energy
security and climate security and
economic security in
um responding to the current
um
issues around energy and really trying
to look to the Future about how we
improve the UK's energy security
um and how we decarbonize our energy
Supply as well so lots of really
um
practical suggestions in there or along
with some high-level commitments from
the from the government
um and you know the the test really is
going to be the extent to which uh you
know the challenges in implementing
those uh the ideas are set out in their
uh are actually overcome because you
know these are complicated difficult
issues to to get to grips with and yeah
um as we've sort of seen from the uh the
previous two reports that I've mentioned
you know there is a real urgency
particularly with energy Supply to be
beginning to get our heads around it
okay thanks David thank you very much
for that anybody have any questions for
David yes Jason I I found the synthesis
um very useful I mean I had read
um the full thing to the ipcc and also
the Climate Change Report
um the and the last one that from the
government the one from the uh about the
the energy I had some issues with
um because there's
um some of the some of the uh things
that have been proposed are untested as
yet
um whereas the one that is the most
tested which is energy Energy Efficiency
the insulation was actually fairly low
down the list but they were all still
very useful to be able to read them
um but how we interpret those and put
them into practice uh as a council would
be extremely you know if other lessons
to be learned there really I suppose
it's my question
yeah I mean in in response to that I
think the um the the key
uh taking that power at Britain report
that the key areas that we'll need to be
thinking about
um are grant opportunities
um I mean you mentioned uh reducing the
Reliance on fossil fuels to eat our
buildings and the insulation
um I think we can certainly expect to
see more
um home energy Green Home energy
conservation grants
um coming on stream over the next few
years in line with the the sort of
government commitments there
um as is
um the sort of uh
incentives to encourage uh renewable
energy
um we already know that there is the
um the the hydrogen fund that the
government's promoting there may well be
opportunities further on down the line
if that technology becomes something
that we want to look into further that
to draw on that I think the other area
that's going to be really important is
the uh the planning side of things I'm
particularly thinking about uh planning
for Renewables and a whole range of
complete competing land uses in rural
areas is going to be really critical
that we get the framework for the South
Wilshire local plan right around that so
that we um we we do encourage
uh Renewables in the right locations uh
and and make make sure that you know our
area is is contributing to
um local energy needs I suppose the
final point is is the role that we might
have around lobbying um so for instance
if you take uh you know the constraints
around the National Grid and the
electricity grid Connections in
particular we know that that's a major
constraint for a lot of uh investment we
know it's a major constraint for
um the decarbonizing our our economy
um and although the governments have
included in here some
um proposals to undertake a review of
that there's nothing really clear about
how that's going to be improved
um and I think it's one of the things
that we can do is to to work with the
likes uh uh of of National Grid as uh
our local
um electricity distribution Network
um as well as sort of not being the
government to try and address those
issues perhaps through organizations
like West Midlands combined authority
too and
some
okay Chicago got a question I think
uh it's just a comment I'd like to see
that report Dave that would be quite
interesting pairing up Britain thank you
and so I'll I I I I I included a link in
in the in the report uh the the meeting
that I'll I'll send you an email with a
link directly to it
okay thanks very much David anybody else
have anything to say
no
okay the final item on the agenda is
urgent business now I understand we have
had a very late question come in
um and uh I've had a chat with Howard
we're going to allow the question but I
may not be able to answer it because
obviously I don't know what it is so uh
it counselor together
thank you chair for allowing the
question now this this was urgent
because obviously something that was
disclosed that full council meeting
yesterday so we know that the current
underspend in the climate change Reserve
uh will be carried forward into the new
year and at the moment uh we will have
well in by 2023-24 there will be a total
of am I right one million 335 000 for
climate change uh uh projects and I
really wanted to ask about uh you know
if we can recommend the creation of a
climate fund which we have raised for
the past three years for Community
groups and Parish councils and local
charities uh to to apply to
um so
well I just want that to be put
um into
uh you know to to ask the panel to to
support that
um and so that we can use some of that
money uh well our our communities can
use some of their money to achieve those
kind of objectives that we have and I
you know if we're not spending the money
now you know for the climate emergency
which is now when are we going to do it
yeah well I've been discussing with
cabinet how we're going to do this uh we
haven't got a an application process yet
for that what we've got to make sure is
it doesn't muddy the waters with sill
requests and seal payments
um and there's a genuine use or a
genuine requirement for a climate change
use for that money
um so again we're at a point where not
sure who the next Administration is
going to be don't know who's going to be
sitting here there or whatever
um so that will wait until after the
election and then if we're still working
on it we'll carry on working on it if
not whoever's the chief of the
administration
um we'll we'll make a plan for how it
it's distributed
okay thank you very much but at least
you will appreciate their counselor
Junior Denario I've raised these for the
past three years
I'm sorry I didn't catch the last the
last sentence it was just that it has
been something that has been raised over
the last three years and just just from
my point of view there are actually
established Grant font you know
processes amongst a number of counselors
councils including South Cambridge
District Council and others that could
be model used as models
okay thank you for that input and like I
say I'll carry that forward take it back
to cabinet and if like I say we're here
we'll do it thank you
councilor cargo wants to come in on that
one
it was only merely a comment that in
principle is a good idea because if you
think about it we're talking probably
small value schemes but the bureaucracy
is what we've got to stop it's like the
leveling up fund I mean it's a great
idea but it's a bureaucracy that's the
problem it throttles it so if we can
come up with a much more efficient way
of of administering this and it's got to
have a business case and all the rest of
it I appreciate all those sort of things
you can't just waste people's money into
taxpayers money at the end of the day
but if we can make a system work that I
think we should really go for it
I agree with that sentiment exactly
thank you
David you'd like to come in again
yes just to say um you know it's a
subject to what uh the new
Administration
um wants to do around this uh
I think um as an office team it may may
be
um but we may be better placed to uh
address this
um uh by then it may because
um a pro it's probably worth me
mentioning anyway that
um a
new post that has been pointed to so the
climate change officer role that
um has been agreed uh is gonna has been
built by somebody called Ellie Warren
who's starting on the 31st of May
um and certainly myself
um and uh I'll be briefing her as a sort
of as a kind of Handover although she'll
still be obviously working very closely
with the uh the the war at climate
change team as well
um but that might well give us some
capacity to begin to develop the scheme
should the new Administration want to
pursue that
thank you David
anybody else have any comments
ah as that's all items on the agenda
completed including the Urgent business
and I declared a meeting closed
thank you
thank you Chad
thanks